Corea del Norte la República islámica de
irano sin ir más lejos La amenaza
nuclear que Vladimir Putin ha repetido
varias veces desde que lanzará su
desastrosa invasión de Ucrania el riesgo
nuclear ahora vuelve a estar sobre la
mesa sí la caída del muro de Berlín el
día 8 de noviembre de 1989 supuso que el
mundo se adentrará en una era de paz
prosperidad y comercio y los hongos
nucleares los simulacros de bombardeos y
los búnkers excavados en las
profundidades de grandes montañas se
convirtieran en cosa del pasado ahora en
cierto modo ese tiempo parece terminado
y esto queridos amigos es algo que se
refleja perfectamente en noticias como
estas Es probable que china tenga 1500
cabezas nucleares en 2035 el pentágono
tres superpotencias nucleares en lugar
de dos marcan el comienzo de una nueva
era estratégica china va camino de
ampliar masivamente su Arsenal nuclear
justo cuando Rusia suspende el último
gran tratado de control de armamento es
el augurio de un nuevo mundo en el de
Pekín Moscú y Washington serán
probablemente rivales atómicos y ojo
porque como veremos en este vídeo parece
que el propio gobierno de Vladimir Putin
también le está dando prioridad absoluta
al rearme nuclear hablamos de un nuevo
entorno político y militar que está
cambiando el equilibrio de poder nuclear
que se forjó en la guerra fría y que ha
hecho que nos hagamos unas cuantas
preguntas dónde y quiénes tienen
exactamente las armas nucleares hoy en
día por qué con tantos frentes abiertos
el kremlin parece estar haciendo del
campo nuclear su prioridad número uno
Qué puede suponer exactamente esta nueva
carrera Pues bien en este vídeo vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas
arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el miedo al desastre nuclear marcó gran
parte de la segunda mitad del siglo XX
tras la Segunda Guerra Mundial poco a
poco más países fueron haciéndose con
esta capacidad por ejemplo en 1949 la
unión soviética acabó con el monopolio
de Washington en 1953 el Reino Unido
hizo lo propio y en 1964 llegaron a la
meta tanto Francia como china sin
embargo con mucha diferencia la unión
soviética y los Estados Unidos fueron
los dos grandes protagonistas de toda
esta historia Esto es algo que todos
sabemos entre ambos países sumaron cerca
del 70% del Arsenal nuclear y tal y como
podéis ver han sido responsables de 1745
de los 2059 ensayos nucleares que se han
llevado a cabo en todo el planeta en
toda la historia y es que no penséis que
cuando hablamos de armas nucleares
hablamos de unas pocas docenas para nada
durante las primeras etapas de la guerra
fría la unión soviética y Estados Unidos
se pusieron como locos a engordar más y
más y más su inventario por ejemplo hoy
para que os en 1962 durante la crisis de
los misiles en Cuba y el botón rojo de
la Casa Blanca contaba ya con
25.540 cabezas nucleares por aquel
entonces la unión soviética sólo tenía
unas 3.346 pero pronto se pondrían las
pilas hasta superar al menos en números
a la propia potencia norteamericana en
total en su punto álgido A mediados de
la década de los 80 se estima que el
inventario mundial llegó a tener unas
70.000 cabezas nucleares me habéis
escuchado bien 70.000 cabezas nucleares
de locos
y así queridos amigos es como se forjó
la conocida como doctrina de la
destrucción mutua asegurada es decir
tanto Estados Unidos como la unión
soviética habían ido tan lejos en la
carrera nuclear que si por cualquier
motivo uno atacaba al otro ambos
quedarían aniquilados ellos y quizás
también buena parte del resto del mundo
Pero esto es algo que ya sabéis es algo
de lo que se ha hablado hasta la
saciedad y lo cierto es que es una
estrategia que funcionó quizás contra
todo pronóstico la doctrina de la
destrucción mutua asegurada hizo que el
mundo fuera un lugar más seguro ahora
bien un momento sabéis que problema
tenía todo esto exactamente pues
imaginaos lo que supone tener decenas y
decenas de miles y miles de cabezas
nucleares susceptibles de que se
produzca en cualquier momento yo que sé
un malentendido una operación terrorista
o un error humano y entonces de repente
el desastre estaría servido y no habría
vuelta atrás y evidentemente cuantas más
armas hubiera más difícil sería
controlarlas debidamente y más
probabilidades habría de que se
produjera algo un fallo Pues bien
precisamente por este motivo las dos
potencias entendieron que tenían que
hacer algo al respecto en concreto
alcanzar acuerdos para poner límites
frenar y reducir este peligro
[Música]
de esta forma En 1968 nació el tratado
de no proliferación nuclear un acuerdo
internacional que frenó en Seco la
carrera de muchos países por dotarse de
este tipo de armas y no sólo eso en 1972
alcanzó el tratado de limitación de
armas estratégicas el Salt 1 un acuerdo
que limitaba el número de misiles
balísticos intercontinentales y de
submarinos balísticos tanto de Estados
Unidos como de la unión soviética luego
en 1979 se fue más allá con la
aprobación del sal 2 el resultado de
todos estos acuerdos pues fijaos como
veis los tratados alt abrieron la puerta
la reducción de los arsenales nucleares
pero no fueron los últimos en el 87 las
dos potencias firmaron un tratado para
limitar las fuerzas nucleares del
alcance intermedio y a partir de 1991
con la unión soviética ya disuelta a
Rusia continuó con la misma política
sellando los acuerdos startuno y Star 2
una versión mejorada de los salta claro
que el descalabro de la unión soviética
y el colapso de su economía hizo que de
repente los Estados Unidos volvieran a
cobrar ventaja Sí a ver como habéis
visto Rusia tenía más armas nucleares
pero muchas de ellas eran antiguas poco
eficientes y las opciones de lanzamiento
Pues digamos que eran mucho muchísimo
más restringidas Estados Unidos en
cambio durante las últimas décadas Ha
logrado desarrollar modernos bombarderos
estratégicos como el b2 submarinos
nucleares y misiles intercontinentales
de mucha mayor precisión y fiabilidad y
todo eso por no hablar de los nuevos
sistemas antimisiles que han ido
surgiendo sistemas como El Tac
para los que no lo conozcáis el tag es
un sistema móvil diseñado para
interceptar misiles balísticos de medio
y largo alcance el hecho de que sea
móvil le permite proteger grandes
territorios o ciudades enteras este
sistema hace uso de un radar avanzado
para detectar y seguir los misiles
enemigos transmitiendo su trayectoria en
tiempo real a otros sistemas de defensa
antimisiles aliados luego también está
el aegis un sistema similar pero operado
desde buques de guerra y sobre todo
tenemos el sistema de intercepción gmd
un sistema continental de defensa contra
misiles balísticos intercontinentales un
programa en el que Estados Unidos ha
invertido más de 100.000 millones de
dólares desde comienzos del siglo XXI Y
que ahora está recibiendo mucha atención
y partidas presupuestarias récord
evidentemente en estos Campos la
superioridad económica y tecnológica de
Estados Unidos pues se nota Así que
digamos que de la destrucción muta
asegurada se pasó a una de confianza
mutua asegurada Aunque lo cierto Es que
la balanza estaba y está cada vez más
desequilibrada en favor de la potencia
norteamericana las características de
los dos sistemas de armas nucleares
complicaban cualquier definición viable
de equilibrio los sistemas estratégicos
soviéticos eran grandes e imprecisos las
armas estadounidenses eran más
transportables y precisas Henry
kissinger en liderazgo y es precisamente
por este motivo por lo que criminal ha
empezado a preocuparse ahora otra vez de
ampliar y renovar sus capacidades
estratégicas O al menos de intentarlo
pero antes de abordar esta cuestión
tenemos que ver dónde estamos
exactamente a nivel global esta queridos
amigos de visualpolitik es una
radiografía del inventario actual de la
fuerza nuclear atentos
las armas nucleares del siglo XXI
creéis un dato sorprendente de unas
70.000 armas nucleares en todo el mundo
se ha pasado actualmente a menos de
14.000 y eso a pesar de que países como
Pakistán Israel la India o Corea del
Norte se han sumado al club nuclear de
hecho con la excepción de China todas
las potencias nucleares históricas han
reducido su Arsenal atómico para que os
hagáis una idea actualmente esta sería
la estimación de armas nucleares por
países que podemos encontrar en todo el
mundo
como veis la reducción paulatina de
cabezas nucleares continuó desde la
década de los 70 Estados Unidos ha
destruido cerca del 80% de su Arsenal y
además de los acuerdos que ya hemos
visto en 2010 el presidente de los
Estados Unidos Barack Obama y el
entonces presidente de Rusia
firmaron en Praga el Start 3 un nuevo
tratado donde se contemplaba una
reducción adicional de un tercio del
Arsenal de cada uno de los dos países
suponía eliminar cerca de 1750 cabezas
nucleares en cada uno de los dos
inventarios en 2021 este acuerdo fue
prorrogado cinco años más claro que su
cumplimiento por parte de Rusia está
siendo muy cuestionado Eso sí sea como
sea menos armas no quiere decir menos
capacidad para que os hagáis una idea el
lgm 30 G minutemann 3 de Estados Unidos
y el rs-28 sarmat ruso los misiles
continentales por excelencia de estos
países tienen cada uno una capacidad
destructiva entre 500 y 1500 veces
superior a la Little Boy lanzada sobre
Hiroshima en 1945
[Música]
Pues bien esta sería grandes rasgos las
características básicas del inventario
nuclear del planeta
y ojo porque aquí tenemos que hacer un
apunte países como Corea del Norte Pese
a que tienen un inventario de armas muy
pequeño o de Irán si finalmente se hace
con la bomba suponen un riesgo enorme
Quizás mucho mayor de lo que podríamos
llegar a pensar a simple vista Por qué
pues por lo que podemos denominar como
el riesgo de la informalidad pensadlo
bien hablamos de dos países parias muy
opacos y con unas élites muy
desconectadas del resto del mundo dos
países que para colmo están
acostumbrados a negociar con la fórmula
de la presión el chantaje y la extorsión
para conseguir sus fines y estos países
podrían por sí mismo provocar el
comienzo de un gran conflicto
internacional por ejemplo se espera que
en poco tiempo Corea del Norte tenga la
capacidad de atacar directamente con
misiles balísticos los mismísimos
Estados Unidos lo que le permitiría
Elevar cualquier apuesta en una mesa de
negociaciones y lo que por supuesto se
traduciría automáticamente en mucha más
tensión y no hablemos ya de posibles
fallos 9 de febrero de 2023 Corea del
Norte despliega suficientes icbms para
abrumar el sistema de defensa
estadounidense contra ellos
administración tras administración han
basado en su intento de impedir que
Corea del Norte desarrolle un número tan
elevado de misiles balísticos
intercontinentales que permitan alcanzar
Estados Unidos precisamente por esto y
también por la aparición de los nuevos
misiles hipersónicos ahora el pentágono
está acelerando los planes de desarrollo
del sistema de defensa antimisiles
por ejemplo el sistema de intersección
gmd que ya os hemos mencionado Incluso
se están desarrollando prácticamente
desde cero nuevos interceptores es lo
que se conoce como el proyecto del
interceptor de Nueva Generación nuevo
sistemas que en el futuro por supuesto
podrían desplegarse también en el resto
de países aliados sistemas que por
cierto están pensados para tratar de
frenar los misiles hipersónicos la
agencia de defensa contra misiles
solicita 10.900 millones de dólares para
el año fiscal 24 y decenas de miles de
millones más a partir de entonces pero
os imagináis que entre tanto se
produjera un fallo y en unos años un
misil de Corea del Norte que se yo
aterrizará no ya en Estados Unidos sino
en países como Japón o Corea del Sur
sería un desastre colosal Y sí podría
terminar provocando un nuevo conflicto a
gran escala pero más allá de estos
riesgos que queréis que os diga por
remotos que sean resultan muy pero que
muy inquietantes ahora llegamos al punto
clave la Guerra de Ucrania ha cambiado
por completo el panorama político y
militar La pregunta es dónde demonios
nos encontramos por qué decíamos al
principio de este vídeo que Putin tiene
entre Ceja y Ceja la fuerza nuclear pues
queridos amigos amigas ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
Cómo son las garras del oso ruso moderno
Vladimir Putin relevó a Mercedes y
regresó a la presidencia en el año 2012
Solo dos años después de la firma del
Star 3 y aunque El dictador ruso nunca
dejó de ser realmente quien mandaba y
Pese a que en 2021 y estuvo a favor de
extender cinco años su vigencia Putin
siempre ha sido crítico con el desarme
nuclear digamos que considera que esta
es una vía que busca sobre todo someter
a los sordos y que precisamente por eso
la madre patria Rusia tiene que seguir
un camino totalmente diferente que donde
queda el acuerdo Star 3 qué más da ya
sabéis que el crimen solo cumple sus
compromisos cuando le conviene aquellos
que en los últimos 15 años han intentado
acelerar una carrera armamentística y
buscar una ventaja unilateral contra
Rusia todo lo que han intentado evitar
con esa política ya ha sucedido nadie ha
conseguido frenar a Rusia Vladimir Putin
en 2018 tras anunciar una nueva serie de
avances en el Arsenal nuclear Ruso y a
ver qué queréis que os diga desde un
punto de vista de realpolitik esta
posición tiene bastante sentido No creo
que sorprenda si os digo que Es evidente
que la única fortaleza que hoy por hoy
tiene Rusia es su Arsenal nuclear sin él
este país no pintaría prácticamente nada
hablamos de un país envejecido con una
economía deprimida desde hace años y
cuyo ejército convencional no está
siendo siquiera capaz de derrotar al
ejército ucraniano por eso su única
ventaja actualmente es la amenaza
nuclear o mejor dicho el chantaje
nuclear 30 de enero de 2023 Boris
Johnson asegura que Putin lo amenazó con
lanzar un misil contra el Reino Unido
pero el kremlin dice que miente 26 de
abril de 2022 labrov advierte sobre no
subestimar amenaza de guerra nuclear en
buena medida estas amenazas es lo que
hicieron que la llegada de ayuda militar
occidental a Ucrania pues no fuera tan
rápida como probablemente hubiera sido y
en un contexto diferente y aunque no
funcionaron del todo es algo que han
repetido una y otra vez desde entonces
27 de febrero de 2023 me debe afirma que
el suministro de armas aquí podría
provocar una catástrofe nuclear mundial
23 de marzo de 2023 medev afirma que
crece La amenaza de una guerra nuclear
pero sabéis que aquí Rusia se enfrenta a
grandes problemas por un lado gran parte
de su Arsenal se está quedando obsoleto
ya habéis visto en ucraneal los enormes
problemas de tecnología fiabilidad
obsolescencia y suministro que tienen
los equipos rusos Pues evidentemente en
el campo nuclear la realidad no tiene
por qué ser excesivamente diferente por
otro lado está la apuesta norteamericana
para desarrollar sistemas antimisiles
[Música]
si Estados Unidos consigue un sistema
eficaz entonces la capacidad de
disuasión de Rusia sería al garete las
presiones competitivas en el campo de
las armas nucleares estratégicas también
podrían verse condicionadas por la
valoración que haga Rusia de las
capacidades de defensa antimisiles de
Estados Unidos
Moscú ha demostrado Que hará todo lo
posible y asumirá costes considerables
para garantizar que sus fuerzas
nucleares estratégicas puedan superar de
forma fiable las defensas antimisiles
estadounidenses evaluación estratégica
de 2020 de la Universidad de la defensa
Nacional de Estados Unidos Esto es lo
que explica que los últimos años hayamos
oído hablar tanto de nuevas armas
estratégicas y razón por la que el
kremlin decidió que un país pobre y con
una economía tan decadente como la rusa
destinará un montón de recursos a
construir nuevos submarinos misiles
hipersónicos y bombarderos estratégicos
que es exactamente lo que muchos habréis
visto en noticias como estas 17 de enero
de 2023 la armada rusa recibe el arma
del Apocalipsis mientras Putin cumple su
amenaza estratégica Poseidón es una de
las armas de Nueva Generación anunciadas
por Moscú hace 5 años con capacidad para
devastar ciudades costeras y atacar
grupos de combate navales sin ser
detectados 17 de febrero de 2023 Rusia
probará un nuevo misil hipersónico en
simulacros con China y Sudáfrica 3 de
abril de 2023 Rusia está expandiendo
rápidamente su flota de submarinos
nucleares Y sí ya sé lo que la inmensa
mayoría estáis pensando pero vamos a ver
Enrique qué me estás contando si los
rusos ni siquiera están siendo capaces
de abastecer el frente y ahora me vienes
con estas supuestas nuevas armas y qué
pasa con las sanciones
Pues sí es verdad tenéis razón si algo
quedó claro en Ucrania es que las
capacidades rusas son como mínimo
cuestionables pero la cuestión es que
esto sí es una gran prioridad para el
kremlin su capital político y quizás
incluso su propia supervivencia dependen
de esta capacidad de disuasión y ojo que
no solo hablo de Vladimir Putin ni
tampoco me estoy refiriendo
exclusivamente a los grandes equipos
militares fijaos Rusia está actualizando
Muchas de sus armas nucleares de menor
alcance denominadas no estratégicas e
introduciendo nuevos tipos parte de la
justificación es que las armas nucleares
no estratégicas son necesarias para
contrarrestar la superioridad de las
fuerzas convencionales de la otan
boletín de los científicos nucleares es
decir hablamos de grandes armas que se
esperan sean capaces de meter miedo en
Estados Unidos y luego de otras armas
más pequeñas y fáciles de construir que
podrían atemorizar a la vieja Europa y
no olvidéis que con una negociación
sobre el conflicto de Ucrania pendiente
este tipo de capacidades pueden ser muy
importantes a la hora de inclinar la
balanza pensadlo bien si quieres
presionar aquí qué mejor que meter miedo
a sus socios 26 de Marzo de 2023 Putin
dice que Moscú colocará armas nucleares
en Bielorrusia Estados Unidos reacciona
con cautela el problema es que todo esto
es algo nuevo puede que penséis que la
Unión soviética o Estados Unidos también
utilizaron su enorme Arsenal nuclear
para amenazar y atemorizar a diestra y
siniestro durante la Guerra Fría pero lo
cierto Es que no fue así digamos que
este era un tema que se trataba con
mucho más cuidado y delicadeza
la unión soviética nunca amenazó con
utilizar un arma nuclear en Afganistán
pese al apoyo que los grupos opositores
recibían de Estados Unidos ni en
Afganistán ni en ningún otro lugar y por
su parte Estados Unidos tampoco amenazó
nunca con utilizar armas nucleares en
Vietnam es decir es algo totalmente
diferente a lo que ahora está haciendo
Putin y también quiñón y quizás los
ayatolas y consiguen la bomba Y esto es
algo que hace saltar todas las alarmas
la consecuencia inmediata Pues que
Estados Unidos tendrá que tomarse mucho
pero que mucho más en serio y con
carácter de urgencia tanto la defensa
antimisiles como la no proliferación lo
que ocurre es que conseguir este en
Europa puede resultar por un factor de
distancia y tiempo mucho más complicado
es posible desarrollar una especie de
cúpula de hierro que cubra al viejo
continente Probablemente sí costaría
mucho dinero muchísimo debería Europa
lanzarse a esta Aventura Pues todo
apunta a que también la poca fiabilidad
que está demostrando no yang sino
también Moscú hace que quizás ya no
baste con la mera disuasión y la
pregunta más importante de todas hará
algo Europa pues probablemente no y
queridos amigos amigas Esta es una de
las grandes bazas con las que sigue
contando para mantener su influencia Y
lograr en el medio plazo nuevas
concesiones Este es el motivo por el que
pese a todo lo que está ocurriendo Putin
sigue r que R con sus fuerzas nucleares
pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti
hasta qué punto consideras que el riesgo
nuclear ha vuelto a crecer crees que
logrará la Rusia de Putin mantener su
capacidad de disuasión podrá Estados
Unidos desarrollar de una vez por todas
un sistema de defensa antimisiles que
sea efectivo Cómo podemos protegernos o
qué tenemos que hacer ante las nuevas
amenazas nucleares dejadnos vuestras
opiniones en los comentarios y hablamos
debate y ahora si este vídeo se ha
resultado interesante ya sabéis no
olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros si
es que aún no lo habéis hecho una vez
más Muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]